hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to be talking about kiten nag
kenag is another one of the throws in I
kiddo that I feel like kind of gets
messed up all the time and there's a lot
of confusion about what it is the way it
looks in the form is fine but if you
tried to apply it the way it looks in
the form you'll probably find it's
really difficult at the same time I feel
like it's a throw that kind of comes off
in rondor and Gaza a fair amount and so
maybe you say oh well it must be an easy
technique but it's not like the form or
the form is right no one can do it right
and so that's why it comes off in Rond
or it comes off wrong you know so
there's all kinds of problems with the
way we look at kenag it just means turn
causing throw a throw that comes from
going around um I'm going to provide my
suggestions and set of answers for you
for kenag I'm not saying that it's right
uh it's probably going to be off the
book from a fair amount of what teachers
have told you or you might tell your
students um I'm not saying that it's
right but this has completely answered
all of the questions I had about kenag
so by looking at kenag this way I've
answered the problems that I had with it
so I'm going to go over those with Josh
today we're going to get him out here
and we're going to go to work Josh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so let's talk about uh kenag
and what kenag is kiten means to go
around if you've ever eaten kiten Sushi
that's a sushi restaurant where they
have a little conveyor belt or maybe a
bunch of little boats or something going
in a circle and they put the plate on
there with sushi on it and you pull the
plate off if you want to eat it and then
there's a color chart on the wall that
tells you how much that plate cost so
kiten just means to go around right so
what does that mean in iido well in iido
the form for kitan pretty consistent l
in most schools looks like this and I
throw this guy and he flies away and
that's a kitan Nagi so kenag might seem
like a weird name for that throw I've
heard before that people say it's called
kenag because of that because it makes
you roll and rolling is kiten and so
then that would make sense like oh it
makes them do a roll but how does that
really distinguish it from a lot of
other throws in iido that make people
take rolls so a lot of things in iido
make people take a roll so how come that
one well you could argue that it's
specifically because it puts their head
down to the ground and they literally
have to take a roll or smash their face
okay so that's reasonable I think
there's really a different kind of
reason that we call it kiten um and I'll
show that in just a second but in the
form one of the problems we have and so
let's just do shanci that's real easy so
I go from here to here I draw this back
I catch his head and I do the throw and
one of the problems you're going to have
is his head is going to be very
difficult to push down so if you're
trying to push his head down that's
going to be hard now I know in the a
system there's a thing about this about
you should hold the head and not the
neck because if you hold the head it's
harder right so meaning if I tried to
grab Josh's neck just stand up for me if
I tried to grab Josh's neck and push him
down Josh can resist that pretty easy
however if I go to the top of his head
he wants to resist that less because
it's difficult on his neck so I know
there are conventions talking about
little tricks to get their head to go
down but when I started having more
success with kenag I realized that I
don't want to make their head go down
they make their head go down and I just
take advantage of it and this is like a
lot of my iido that I realize there is a
situation created where he'll want to do
something and my job is to capitalize
upon that instead of trying to force him
to do that so instead of trying to force
this guy to do it there are situations
where he will put his head down now
those same situations will actually also
create a situation like this which is
much like a kiten so yes he's probably
going to do a roll out of it but also
it's going to create a kiten situation
let me explain let's say we were in
okay and I use triangle to get out boom
okay now Josh can't unless he's way more
powerful than me come in on this line
right because my hand's in the way okay
so going under that is very reasonable
and you see this in wrestling and all
kinds of Styles now if he goes low and I
go low he'll go lower and I'll go lower
and he'll go lower and I'll go lower now
look at what just happened now if I stay
right here when Josh does that you see
how my legs available to him he's going
to get my legs he's going to pull them
out from under me however if if when he
goes to grab that leg I turn like this
we notice what starts to happen a really
really effortless kitag we're kiening in
this way not in this way and I'm not
saying that the original definition
because you know zle kiten is a forward
role that makes sense with this but if
you think about the fact of the struggle
that's happening like this and then when
we start to plug it into our context
it'll make a lot more sense so
understand that I'm always trying to get
over here and then ideally back here now
if he's chasing me around that and I'm
putting my hand in his way as he's
chasing me around that that throw comes
off with me doing almost nothing right
so kitag toi is our basic defense for
low leg attacks and it comes off that
way for mainly two parts one is from any
kind of wide attack I one want to put
something in the middle so he can't just
enter in there and then two I'm going to
try and keep my space here now as he
comes into that I'm going to move myself
out and out and out until eventually we
get a kitan out of that right so the
kenag comes because he keeps pushing in
and I won't let him come up now if he
chose to come up that'd be fine we'd do
a different throw tons of stuff like
suot to come off of that immediately
right so meaning if we're down like this
and Josh decides oh I want to come up
sum to comes in there's all kinds of
other thrs KAG um all kinds of stuff can
happen in that but understanding that
concept of the kitag happens because
they're trying to get into that space
and you won't let them and so they're
going under to circumvent that so
they're getting lower and lower and
lower and charging in at you we get this
spinning spiraling kind of thing that
creates our kiten throw so that's the
way I personally think about kiten nag
coming off and I think of the kiten
happening more this way than this way
although one doesn't cancel out the
other that's why it's it's full of kiten
it's full of this turning around kind of
energy and I think the most important
kiten is I'm always trying to get out
and they're always chasing me and that's
what's making this throw happen so
that's the context for kenag so that's
the way I explain kenag it might be
fairly different from the way it's
explained in your school um and I'm not
saying my Way's right but it just
answers all of my questions when I look
at kenag that way I don't have questions
about it anymore so if that helps you I
hope it does actually help you yeah so
anyways I'm Christopher hind this is
Joshua T and my Sal mcdel is right
behind that Center one right now we'll
see you guys in the next video
[Music]
oh